maybe if we gave Peter a really  wonderful Christmas gift it would make  him happy  kind of present  something special he will never forget  what about someone special  what or the year school has talked about  one person more than any other a  legendary hero who has saved countless  lives we could give him the quilt as a  present  [Music]  yeah can I help you  yes we're looking for the legendary  Kevin Bacon we're looking for the  legendary Kevin Bacon  your voice is small and mousy I think  maybe he didn't hear you heard it's  Kevin Bacon he's probably got great ears  I'm sorry guys  I can't help  you you think you can toss me over the  gate if you  [Music]  oh  what are you doing tossing you over the  gates  I didn't mean right that second I meant  after I was ready  I wasn't even done talking tossed you  over the gate don't touch over the gate  make up your mind  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  don't just take stuff  [Music]  but I guess that's what it's here for  [Music]